وناجازاكي بالفي ضعف. يا الهي هل
نشهد نهاية العالم بيونج يانج
باليستي ما اثار مخاوف في كل دول
العالم كونها في مرمى الزعيم
النووي. انفجارها اقوى من
القنبلة الذرية بعشرة الاف ضعف
اخبركم ان هناك شخصا مجنونا
يمتلك النسخة الاخرى منها. او
كيف ذلك؟ وميض يعمي الابصار.
وسحب تحجب الشمس واثار كارثية
اي اقوى من القنبلة اسقطتهما
الولايات المتحدة على هيروشيما
الهيدروجينية في حال تفجيرها
والتي يعتمد عملها على الاندماج
بالاصح شقيقتها الصغرى. النسخة
الكورية بيد كيم. الزعيم الكوري
على العالم كله. هذا ما ستحدثه
قنبلة كوريا الشمالية
لم يكن بعيدا عن الاسلحة النووية
فهو ايضا يمتلك مفتاحا العالم.
القيصر او ايفان اقوى البلدان
العالمية وعلى رأسها الولايات
اعلنت تجربة هذه القنبلة وانها
تمكنت من تحميلها على صاروخ
الكوري. المجنون ما زال يهدد
بتفجير قنبلته المرعبة في الهادئ
ما سيتسبب باثار بيئية
وجيوسياسية كارثية. برأيكم هل
لاول مرة في التاريخ لقد تحدثنا
عن قنبلة القيصر. ولكني نسيت ان
الاسلحة النووية في الفضاء وتحت
سطح الماء وعلى سطح ارض. فما
تحقيق التكافؤ النووي مع
الولايات المتحدة. في اغسطس اب
هذه القنبلة لن تستخدم للاغراض
العسكرية بل لغرض واحد فقط وهو
تم تفجير قنبلة نووية عادية في
المرحلة الاولى لتوليد الحرارة
المتحدة الامريكية قيادة الاتحاد
السوفيتي. كانوا يدركون جيدا مثل
والاتحاد السوفيتي وبريطانيا على
المعاهدة التي تحظر اختبار
لم يتم استخدام القنبلة بشكل
كامل. ولغرض التخفيف من قوتها
فيها عبارات. امريكا لا تفهم الا
لغة القوة. لقد صدمت قنبلة
الذرية التي اسقطتها الولايات
المتحدة الامريكية على هيروشيما.
رأيكم هل فعلا امريكا لا تفهم
الا لغة القوة كما قالها الروس
الانفجار. وقد نجحوا في مسعاهم.
وقد مر التفجير بثلاث مراحل. حيث
المرحلتين التاليتين والتي تؤدي
الى توليد قوة تدميرية هائلة
تقريبا. كل هذا فقط من صوت
الانفجار وبسبب الاشعاع
كسب القليل من الوقت لينجو طاقم
الطائرة من الانفجار. تم تفعيل
الف كيلومتر من نقطة الانفجار.
في القرى المجاورة له دمرت
في السماء اكثر من اربعة وستين
كيلو مترا وبعرض اربعين كيلو
مترا. بالرغم من الغيوم الكثيفة
لوحظ وجود خفيف على بعد اكثر من
المباني السكنية وفقدوا الاتصال
اللاسلكي لمدة خمسين دقيقة
بانفجارها ربع سكان العالم وجميع
دول اوروبا ارتفع حجم الانفجار
الكهرومغناطيسي بلغت قوة قنبلة
القيصر حوالي ثمانية وخمسين
واحدا في المائة فقط. يا لقد
اوشكوا على مصافحة ملاك الموت.
الحر للقنبلة كان احتمال بقاء
الناس في القاذفة على قيد الحياة
العالية التي تتطلبها عملية
تحفيز الاندماج النووي لنظائر في
سبعة وخمسين ميجا طن. كما قاموا
بوضع نظائر الرصاص بدل
تقاس بالميجا طن. مكاسب روسيا من
التجربة. هنا كانت اول مرة تقال
قنبلة ايفان الكبير. اخطر سلاح
صنعته الايادي البشرية. وللعلم
عام الف وتسعمائة وثلاثة وستين.
وقع ممثلو الولايات المتحدة
القنبلة. تبع ذلك انفجار استمر
حوالي دقيقة ثم ارتفعت ساق الفطر
فقد قام العلماء السوفييت بتخفيض
قوة القنبلة من مائة ميجا طن الى
اليورانيوم من اجل تقليل كميات
الغبار الذري المنبعث عن
مليون طن من مادة تي ان تي. هذا
اقوى بثلاثة الاف مرة من القنبلة
نوفايا. بعد ساعتين من المغادرة
اسقطت القنبلة بمظلة من ارتفاع
ثلاث موجات زلزالية من الانفجار
دارت لثلاث مرات حول الارض. شعر
واضطر المصممون الى قطع جزء من
جسم القاذف الاستراتيجية وتثبيت
لطاقم الطائرة الناقلة بالانتقال
الى مسافة امنة نسبيا مع السقوط
النووي في اربعين ثانية لتخلف
هنا وميضا عظيما. لتأتي بعدها
الاتحاد السوفيتي. ما دفع
الحكومة الى اعطاء الضوء الاخضر
بسرية تامة واستخبارات دقيقة تم
اعداد طائرة حاملة. كان طول
انخفض نظام المظلة الى ارتفاع
اربعة الاف ومائتي متر. والهدف
لاستئناف التجربة. المكان الخبير
الزمان في العشرين من اكتوبر.
القنبلة حوالي ثمانية امتار
وعرضها حوالي مترين ولا تصلح.
صباح يوم الثلاثين من اكتوبر
حلقت طائرتان من القاعدة باتجاه
قاعدة خاصة. لكن رغم ذلك كان نصف
قنبلة القيصر خارجا من الطائرة
لم يكن هناك رافعة مناسبة
لنقلها. لذا كان من الضروري بناء
السوفيتي سابقا في عام الف
وتسعمائة وواحد وستين حدث تصعيد
علينا فقط اختبارها. هكذا قال
هانيكي ليهدد رئيس الاتحاد
مليون طن من نعم ارتجفت الارض
ثلاث مرات من قوة التفجير
الامريكية كوبا. هنا اشتعلت
نيران الغضب في قلوب قيادة
خط سكة حديد منفصل في التجميع
العسكري. الرعب التاريخي. في
حوالي عشرة الاف متر. كان نظام
المظلة ضروريا للغاية فقد سمح
وللقصة بقية. فليعلم اولئك الذين
يحلمون بشن عدوان جديد اننا
اخر للصراع في برلين بدأوا في
اقامة جدار حدودي. غزت القوات
نمتلك قنبلة المئة مليون طن ولن
نخبركم ماذا يختبئ في احشاء وبقي
ومراحله. فما الذي حدث في ذلك
اليوم. عن الموت الروسي نتحدث
ايفان الكبيرة والمعروفة بقنبلة
القيصر في الغرب. والتي يعادل
تفجيرها اكثر من ثلاثة الاف ضعف
لقنبلة هيروشيما او تفجير خمسين
نعم في ذلك اليوم فجرت روسيا
قنبلة الموت او كما تسمى قنبلة
وتصرح تقلقوا ونأسف لازعاجكم.
لقد اجرينا تجربتنا التاريخية.
القاتم جفت الحروق وتوقف العقل
عن التبكير. لتظهر هنا روسيا
ليصلوا ظنا انها النهاية شاهد
انفجارها ربع سكان الارض. الكثير
يصيحون ما الذي يحدث ما هذا
التوهج وما كل هذا الدخان الاحمر
عندما سمعوا صوتها ظنوا انها
نهاية العالم. ارعى الكثير
سيجرؤ الزعيم الكوري على تفجير
هذه القنبلة?